[Music]
if you have an ambivalent reaction to
the announcement of a new Dumbo movie we
don't blame you on one hand it's a
remake of the beloved Disney classic by
the talented director Tim Burton on the
other hands the original movie has some
troubling elements that don't really
stand the test of time
but the true story behind Dumbo is even
more troubling than most people realized
before we get into the disturbing real
story behind Dumbo be sure to hit the
subscribe button for more videos from
the things for a long time elephants for
a huge draw when it came to circuses and
it's easy to see why elephants are
fascinating intelligent creatures that
most people never have a chance to see
in the wild but they need a lot of care
and resources and few circuses can
commit to caring for them properly in
addition the tricks that so delight
audiences aren't natural elephant
behavior by any means in order to train
elephants to do such things
they need to undergo things that most
people would consider incredibly cruel
even the famous Ringling Brothers and
Barnum & Bailey Circus has vowed to
phase out elephant acts because of
public concerns elephants have complex
social structures and circus life and
training is incredibly traumatic for
them and that was the case with the real
elephant that Dumbo was based on as fans
of the classic Disney film know the
beloved baby elephants real name is
jumbo jr. and Dumbo is a cruel nickname
given to him by his peers
there was once a real elephants named
jumbo and he arrived at the London Zoo
in 1865 during his time at the circus he
was hit with visitors who frequently
enjoyed riding on this enormous elephant
sadly elephant riding still persists to
this day despite the fact that we know
it's horrible for the health of
elephants most people never question
this because elephants are so big and
strong but they aren't designed to hold
heavyweights on their backs carrying
around humans and living in cramped zoo
conditions meant that poor Dumbo
suffered these intense pains during his
relatively short life
eventually the Jews sold him to PT
Barnum for use in the circus in recent
times the bones of jumbo have been
examined and revealed how the
of stress had damaged him jumbo was only
24 years old when he passed away but his
bones showed painful wear and tear that
would be expected from an elephant twice
his age and if you think about it we see
the same type of thing happening with
the animated elephants in the movie
Dumbo particularly with mrs. jumbo she's
separated from her baby punished for
displaying normal elephant behaviour and
kept in cramped conditions sadly that's
actually an incredibly accurate
depiction of what life is like for the
vast majority of elephants in captivity
the real jumbo started out as a docile
elephant but soon became prone to
violent rages particularly in the
evening
this is the reason why the two
eventually considered him a liability
and sold him to the circus e-stat if the
London Zoo lacked the resources to care
for jumbo properly it's pretty baffling
to expect that a circus would according
to witnesses during the day
jumbo seemed to calm and content when
the Sun went down it was a different
story he would become possessed with
violent rages and destroy anything that
was in his path during these fits he
would even harm himself and one point he
broke off both of his husks when they
grew back he would use the stone of his
enclosure to grind them back down it got
so bad that his keeper Matthew Scott
resorted to giving him whiskey to try to
calm him down obviously that's an
unorthodox approach and something we
also saw happen in the movie Dumbo yes
that was clearly made in a different
time when it was okay to show baby
animals getting intoxicated in
movie let's consider the fact that a
fictional baby jumbo is so distraught at
being separated from his mother that he
sobs hysterically and then accidentally
gets drunk
would you mother think of you if she saw
you crying like this but with the
real-life jumbo his rages were written
off with the excuse that he was going
through maturity it's not unusual for
male elephants to become aggressive
during this time however modern
researchers disagree and add that if
this was the case
jumbo would have also become aggressive
to his keepers but this was not the case
current scientists who have examined his
remains for these there is a sad with
simple solution to his nighttime rages
elephants teeth grow and fall out
constantly but if their teeth don't wear
down properly they won't fall out
naturally this means that the new tooth
will be blocked causing a terrible
amount of pain in addition to not being
fed properly jumbo has fed tons of
sweets and snacks by well-meaning
patrons without the distractions
provided by daylight hours poor jumbo is
left alone with an excruciating pain in
his mouth for which he found no release
oh and those fun circus trains that we
see in the movie Dumbo the real jumbo
met his end when he was struck by a
locomotive the lives of circus elephants
are undeniably tragic but that's true
for many of the human performers as well
the history of circuses is long and
storied and filled with gross violations
of human rights you've probably heard of
people selling their kids to the circus
and that's actually a thing that
happened frequently people with
disabilities or medical problems would
be sold to circuses and forced to
perform for crowds of spectators gawking
at people who look different from us is
something that's generally frowned upon
in modern society but for a shockingly
long period of human history it was
perfectly acceptable freak shows were as
profitable as they were degrading and
for the most part their living
conditions were deplorable and let's not
forget perhaps the most uncomfortable
part of Dumbo the crows most children
probably didn't think anything of the
cheerful and helpful group of crows we
saw in the movie but as an adults the
cringe is really strong first of all
there's the fact that the main crow is
named Jim Crow
after racial segregation laws this casts
such a shameful pall over the movie and
it's sort of baffling that they're
honoring the film with a you make sure
there are a lot of things about Dumbo
that we enjoyed as children but looking
back the story is actually incredibly
disturbing and Disney's portrayal of it
is offensive are we really so low on
ideas for new movies that we have to
remake stories about animal cruelty what
do you think about the movie Dumbo are
you excited for the remake or do you
think reviving this film is in poor
taste let us know what you think in the
comments section and then hit the
subscribe button to get access to more
videos from the things bye for now
[Music]